hello everyone and welcome to another
game from day three of the st. Louis
rapid omits event we already saw one
game yesterday where a magnus carlsen
won a very nice game against maxi
marshall a grove in the gloom fall
defense here he faces his old rival from
the 2016 World Championship
Sarah Kerrigan it's a crossing with the
black pieces so without further ado
let's just check it out as again it's
it's a very nice game and a lot of you
have requested it so kurakin opens with
d4 with Knight to f6 c4 e6 and now
Knight to f3 Carlsen goes for well he
doesn't like Knight c3 to invite Carson
sorry Carson doesn't like Knight c3 to
invite Carlsen for the nimzo-indian so
instead Knight to f3 but still Bishop to
b4 check we have the BOGO Indian defense
and now Knight to Knight bTW to the most
commonly played move is Bishop to b2 and
just either asking black do you want to
trade right away or do you want to
retreat with a bushel but here we have
Knight BD to buy kurakin preparing a3
where you will either have to give up
Bishop for a night or you will have to
go back with the bishop so we have
castles bye-bye Carlsen a3 now as
planned and of course cost and retreats
he wants to keep his bishop pair we have
E for black red or white grabs the
center and then now d6 with Bishop to e2
by hurricane preparing the castle and
Knight B to d7 with Queen to c2 and now
c5 challenging the center and now you
can decide whether you want to just do
something else maybe castle maybe I
decide to push on the Queen sir would be
for but car can decides to grab more
space in the center so we have b5 and
now there are a couple of moves that
have been played here Knight g4 has been
played here Knight h5 has been played
rook e8 has been played
pawn captures pawn has been played but
the move cross in place causing the
center is a new move in this position
and it is already as a move 9 that we
have a completely new game so tonight's
the f1 now preparing Knight g3 to maybe
grab the DF 5 square with his Knight and
a6 now calls and prepares B six maybe
even b5 in some lines the field cut off
his light square bishop and get it into
the game we have Knight to g3 as planned
and now g6 just preventing Knight to f5
we have castles by cracking and the now
comes Knights th now freeing the well
freeing this space for the corn to be
pushed to f5 you want to get F 5 F 4 in
and so on as you do in most Indian
defenses with beef or by car cane and
now Knight the g7 further supporting the
F 5 square and now if kirkin did sound
like rook e1 most likely we would see f5
but here keratin goes Bishop to h6 and
here it would be a bit dangerous to play
a 5 as you would just
well for starters lose a pawn and pretty
much ruin your structure in front of the
King for example if f5 you also have to
notice that the Queen covers it so just
captures captures and now you grab a
pawn if black three characters Knight
captures an f5 to the Queen defends the
knight and the black is just broken on
the Kings side
so after Bishop h6 will be 6 by Carlsen
preparing to fianchetto the light square
bishop and now rook a to b 1 hurricane
is now ready to open up the B file he
wants to play rugby 2 and bring the
other look over to be won the double up
rooks on the B file with a 5 by Carlson
and then I'll just h3 taking away the g4
square from black also making some more
room on the King side for the King but
also maybe ideas like night H 2 T g4
will be possible in the future
well kink the a trade by Carlson and now
comes Luke the B to preparing rugby 1s
planned it captures 8 captures and now
Knight back to f6 preparing Knight the
g8 to kick away the Bishop from h6 and
only then will cause and be able to
execute f5 we have B captures and c5 b
captures on c5 and i just want to
mention something doesn't really have
anything to do with this game a lot of
you not a lot of you but some of you
have been saying that watching my videos
on your smartphones is hard due to the
subtitles but i don't turn on the
subtitle of this the subtitles are
turned on on your account so if you want
subtitles to disappear you have to
remove them on your own devices as i
don't have any sort of power where do i
turn on or off the subtitles on your
device i just remembered that so i
thought i would just say it now
so carotene continues with his plan of
rook F to be one and now if you look at
this position Corrigan has a nice pin
here and the King said he has complete
control of the B file with the rooks
definitely White has the advantage here
with nice the g8 by cross and as planned
the bishop is now under attack and here
Bishop back to d2 we have f5 finally by
Carlsen preparing f4 with rook to b8
captures captures and now Carlsen pushes
f4 kicks the knight back with Knight to
f1 now with ideas of night h2 followed
by Knight to g4 and Carson continues
pushing on the Kings side with g5 we
have Queen to a4 here preparing Bishop
to a5 to activate the bishop and also
harass the black queen with h6 by
Carlsen now strengthening the g5 form
and and now we have Bishop to a5 as
planned
Queen to d7 a call center offers afraid
of Queens and if you did this then black
will just be able to trade down and
Carson wouldn't really have any problems
here so here Corrigan says okay let's
trade Queens but we will trade Queens on
my terms if you want to trade Queens you
have to capture on c6 and this will give
me a nice pass pawn on c6 so first
crossing goes Knight to f6 now preparing
to bring the knight into the game also
if captures the knight can capture on d7
also maybe ideas like h5 and g4 are
possible and now kirkin starts getting
the night into the game we have night
f12 d2 and here at crossing captures
with Queen captures D captures and now
Knight the e6 getting the knife to help
out well with with the pushing of the
pawn and also now cross and is ready to
play Bishop basics so car soccer keen
prevents it with rook to e8 not allowing
bishop tastes x4 course and to trade
more material but Carson finds a way he
plays Bishop to d8 and now he says okay
if you capture my brush but see then I
capped ran a five and then after we
trade rooks check check the knight is
under attack you have to play some of
like 93 or not be one I'm gonna move the
dish back and then
I'm gonna go after your ceased exponent
which is not a weakness not a strength
some like night well you can play no 96
maybe night is 7 and then harass the
pawn this way
so instead after Bishop to d8 curtain
doesn't capture and c8 correcting
captures the bishop with Bishop capture
some d8 rook captures and e8 and now
Bishop to d1 now getting the bishop
activated via the a for square we have
night the c7 attacking the rook and now
looked a seven by kurakin Knight ft 8
and here comes Knight to h2 we have
Bishop to e6 by Carlsen and now Busch up
to h5
just putting pressure on the night there
and here we've roped the c8 which is not
the best idea here best for cross and
his King g8 and King f8 the King has to
help out with the defense here but
crossing plate Knight to c8 and kirkin
found a very nice way of how to take
advantage of this position so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
this sneaky idea Kirk and played in this
position while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent finder of good squares for the
night and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show
Knight to g4 just attack the h6 pawn and
black has no ways of defending the pawn
because if you play something like King
defense team g7 then white just wins
apiece better capture 78 on e8 and well
you cannot capture as the knight is
pinned if rook captures then you lose
the other night with check as well so
after 94 with Bishop Tadros energy for
Magnus is forced to give up the lights
work up here with Bishop captures
attacking the rook and now rook to e8
cross and hopes to trade more material
but kurakin says no no sir we'll look to
b7 and now it's very hard for Carson to
make a move well if you move this night
you lose this night
and there's there's not all that much to
do this night doesn't have all that many
squares you could go to a 6 but where's
the night going from a 6 so cross and
starts activating the king we have king
to g7 and now Kirk in plays Bishop to be
it's the same idea when we explained why
the king cannot come here the thread is
Bishop captures here as the knight on c7
is pinned so King to f6 Magnus gets out
of the way and now Knight to be won and
here nice to be won as usual the
strongest and hardest move to find is
with the knight back with Knight be one
car can now plans Knight to c3 and night
to b5 from where there will be yet a
more attack to the night and c7 you
cannot defend it further as the best of
guards the c8 square and of course if
black captures you will then be able to
fix your pawn structure and you will
have two connected passed points on the
Queen side so this is Cara conspan with
Knight day 6 by magnets preparing to
bring the other night over there with
knife to a6 and here you could capture
on e8 but kurakin decides to just
continue with his plan with Knight to c3
we have Knight eat the c7 and now just
nice to be 5 so did this really do
anything for Magnus not really as the
threat is still the same if you capture
you get to connect the fast points here
there's really no playing this 97 b6
whatever you play Knight a 6 C 7 there's
just no stopping the bones here so after
Knight b5 we have Knights to ecigs by
Magnus and now comes Bishop captures on
e6 King captures on e6 and now we get
Knights to a7 not not pushing c7 right
away so first knife to a7 taking away
the c8 squared from Carlson's rook so
you cannot stop the passed pawn with h5
by Magnus he no longer has a move on the
Queen side so he decides to push on the
Kings side with f3 and now g4 h captors
H captures correctly and just grabs the
phone with F captures and now rook to g8
as cross and just created a target on g4
we have king to f2 and now rook captures
on g4 and now look the b6 also very nice
idea with c7 here for example if c7 you
have to give up the night you just grab
it and then rook the g3 where call where
Kerrigan would now have a full night be
a full night up but you will be down
upon but he decides that this is maybe
too much work as he is very low on clock
on
a minute so he decides for a different
idea he plays rook to b6 attacks the
knight Knight to c7 and now Knight b5
again with the same idea either you
capture and I fix my pawn structure or I
grab your knight
so we have looked to g7 by cross and
defending and now look at the b7 and
here you have to now do something there
is no more you know
horsing around with nice - eh and here
Kerrigan played rook to b8 again
harassing the night but also a very
interesting idea was just capturing the
rook rook captures Knight actress and
now c7 allowing King 37 the King now
stops the pond but of course you will
see how white wins here it's a very nice
idea you just capture here and now if
you capture with the King well why'd you
get the Queen enter game if you don't do
anything the CH square is not protected
by the night so you would have to
capture the pawn here and now 9 if 7
goes after the e5 pawn you cannot defend
it as the knight also covers the d6
square so the King cannot approach the
pawn and it would just be a winning
endgame but you know time is very scarce
on the clock so Kara King goes for a
more natural line rook to b8 attacked
the night we have Knight the c7 and here
Kirk in just plays rook to d8 and it was
in this position on mu 53 that Magnus
Carlsen resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to do here really you don't
have any moves you could capture on d5
but then seek after some b5 the two
connected passed pawns or just monsters
if you don't do this just rook captures
or Knight captures here is the threat
you're gonna lose a very important based
on the pawn chain
so all the other pawns will fall as well
and even though Kerrigan had I believe
11 seconds in this position in cost and
head over a minute it doesn't really
matter as you do have a 10 second delay
so before you play any move you get 10
seconds before that so it's really not a
problem there was no way of flagging the
opponent here but yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and I will
mention the standings as I don't know if
I will be if I will have time to make
more videos today from the rapid section
so if you're not interested in the
standings you know close your eyes or
something but here are the stand
are those de standings really so small
sorry I'm on my laptop still haven't
figured all of it out but there we have
it after three days of rapid in first
place with 13 points
maxime beaugeois graphic are in an 11
was leading the entire tournament
but then Maxine caught up then with 10
points Bingley Ren and you young II and
then magnus carlsen Fabiana cora wanna
sergey kurginyan richard report with 8
points Dominguez Perez Lanier with 7 and
Sharma media of last with 5 points so
really ma media of sometimes he just
obliterates the the opposition with with
you know clinching first place but
sometimes he just you know trolls around
in last place and we'll see what the
Carson will be able to do he is now at
in fifth place with 8 points but it will
be hard to get back on top in this
tournament as now we have the two days
of blitz section and for blitz you only
get to one point for victory as in rapid
you get two points for victory so
basically those who win the rapid
section mostly win the entire tournament
but you never know you know what will
happen
yeah once again that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
think of the solemn of the solemn for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check too in my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
soon
continuing the coverage of this nice
event when I return to my hometown
tomorrow
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course continuing the
capablanca saga which is very close to
the end so thank you I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day